Speaker 1: When it comes to vaccine mandates,
there are really two or three major questions.
Are they legal? Are they moral and do they
work now? Are they legal? Is something that
in the United States is essentially
settled. Now you'll hear people say
it's unconstitutional. These are the same people
that say the 2020 election was unconstitutional.
We asked them, Well, what? What exactly was
violated from the Constitution? They don't know.
But the legality of vaccine requirements,
particularly when there's a test out policy
is is really without question at this point
in time, even without a test out policy for
things like attending school or whatever the
case may be. We've had examples of these going
back more than 100 years in the United States, in
different places. The legality, no matter what you
hear on wherever, Facebook, right wing media,
etc., the legality is really not in question.
The morality is a different type of question. When
we think about questions that we want to answer,
the first thing we have is we have to determine
what kind of a question it is. Zero is a question
with an empirical answer how much hydrogen
is there in atmospheric air that we breathe
or whatever. That's one type of question. Is it
wrong to steal bread to feed your family? Well,
OK, that's it. But if you're morally, that's
a judgment call. And the question of morality
is more of a judgment call, and it can be debated
and it's not what we're doing today. The third
question is do vaccine mandates work? And there
are many on the right who have sought to make it
seem like vaccine mandates don't work by talking
about the number of whatever that are threatening
to quit if they have to get vaccinated, saying
they will quit writing a letter stating they will
quit. And every single time that that happens,
I take the position of let's not go by what the
union is threatening. Let's not go by what people
are posting on social media. Let's just go by the
number of people that actually quit. And we have
a new data point and it's from the New York Police
Department. Despite threats and hyperbole that
up to a third of NYPD might quit over the vaccine
mandate, 10000 officers might quit as of this
morning. Thirty four officers have defied the
vaccine mandate out of 36000, meaning zero point
zero nine percent. There is literally no effect on
service at this point, says New York City Police
Commissioner Dermot Shea. New York City's vaccine
mandate for municipal workers has taken effect.
And just 34 police officers have refused it,
a far cry from the 10000 threatened by the
NYPD union under the mandate announced by Mayor
Bill de Blasio, all city municipal employees,
including police, firefighters and civil servants,
must either get vaccinated or be put on unpaid
leave. Hundreds of city workers protested the
mandate and the New York Police Department's
largest union, the Police Benevolent Association,
claimed it would take thousands of cops
off the streets. As of Thursday morning,
the PBA warned last week there were ten
thousand unvaccinated uniformed NYPD members,
which equals the staffing of dozens of patrol
precincts who will be barred from reporting for
duty on Monday, November one, unless they have
applied for religious or medical exemption.
The union's president, Patrick Lynch, particularly
slammed Police Commissioner Dermot Shea
for going along with the plan. Commissioner
Shea and his team should have told the mayor
this mandate and his arbitrary Friday deadline.
We're going to throw NYPD operations into chaos
on Monday, however, the chaos failed to
materialize. Less than three dozen NYPD officers
were put on unpaid leave, and the department
reported no interruption in service. Here
is Andrew Giuliani. Rudy Giuliani's son, who's
running for governor, saying 27 percent of NYPD
may be gone. Take a look from police department
Speaker 3: issue and staffing. We're looking at
potentially losing twenty seven percent of
the NYPD at this moment. I think 73 percent
of the NYPD has actually lost. Has the vaccine.
Speaker 1: So my position has continued to be,
let's see how many of them actually do it. And
the real number is thirty four out of 36000. Now,
remember? What is the question we are answering?
The fact that it's only 34 doesn't mean the
vaccine mandate is morally right. I believe it is,
but it's important that we understand what is the
question we're asking and what is the question
that we are answering? The vaccine mandate is
working now. These thirty four officers, they
may well find themselves looking around wondering
what happened to my pension, what happened to my
salary? What happened to my health care coverage?
They may regret this decision. OK, but the point
is it's only 34 individuals. I also would expect
that many of these 34 are mad at the rest of the
36000 that went ahead and got vaccinated. OK, that
is a really common thing in these situations where
those who are the ones that are the outliers,
those who are the ones that are doing what
I believe is not good for their communities
or their families or their jobs are for anything.
They will be mad at everybody else for caving
to the man and complying, etc.. Also, big
picture step back and think about the numbers
for a moment. 80 percent of U.S. adults
have received at least one dose so far,
80 percent of U.S. adults are what we would
call at least partially vaccinated right now.
There's probably a bunch of lying going on about
people claiming not to be vaccinated and actually
being vaccinated for social pressure reasons.
Anecdotally, we know this is true. We saw a
very interesting report on a recent live stream of
CNN reporter who went to I don't remember where it
was some state in the south and interviewed
a guy who was very much against the vaccine
six nine months ago, and he said, I did get it. I
did get it, but I have not told anyone in my life
because of the social pressure not to get the
vaccine. I mean, mathematically, when 80 percent
of U.S. adults have gotten at least one vaccine
dose, you know that there are people who are
simply lying about it. These thirty four police
officers in New York City to go back to that for
a moment. I got a very interesting email, which
I'll read in full for you on Friday in my mailbag.
And they said, you know, we talk about the few bad
apples that spoil the bunch in police departments.
The 34 who refused to get vaccinated. These
might be exactly the types of officers we want
gone anyway because we talk about the George
Floyd situation or whatever the case may be.
And I continue to believe because of what I see,
that most officers have the right intentions and
want to do what's right. These 34 who are refusing
to do what's right morally, in my opinion,
might be the exact types of officers that we would
want not on the force as as it is now. Again, for
those who think the vaccine mandates don't work.
Clearly, they do. We have seen health systems with
about a one percent refusal rate, and it seems
to be exactly the type of people we want gone
who are leaving anyway, right? I mean, nurses
who refuse to do what's right for patient safety
are the ones who are ending up unvaccinated and
quitting or getting fired from hospital systems.
That's good. That's good. Sounds like a good
thing not to have those folks providing care.
The police officers who either don't want
rules to apply to them or believe wrongly,
that there's something illegal about such a
requirement. These are the ones that are quitting.
Maybe these are the ones that we want to see quit.
As it is, the mandates are working really well.
And whenever you hear, oh, 20 percent
are saying or are currently unvaccinated,
let's wait to see how many actually end up out
of their jobs. It's a very small number. And
the argument can strongly be made that these are
folks we probably don't want in those jobs anyway